let's go back to that point you were
making about maybe the security issue
because we have this story from
bloomberg warnings of
warnings of another capital attack
raised tensions in washington
bloomberg's reporting that law
enforcement warnings that a militia
group may be plotting to attack the us
capital on thursday
raised tensions again in washington and
helped prompt the house to cancel plans
to meet for votes that could explain why
joe biden has not given a state of the
union address as you mentioned
quote we have obtained intelligence that
shows a possible plot to
breach the capital by an identified
militia group on thursday march 4th
the u.s capitol police said in a
statement wednesday we are taking the
intelligence seriously
that alert followed a joint intelligence
bulletin late tuesday from the homeland
security department
and the federal bureau of investigation
about extremists discussing
carrying out attacks at the capitol from
march 4th to march 6.
melissa smith lova a senior homeland
security official told two senate
committees
about the threat on wednesday the police
warning did not give specifics citing
sensitive nature of the information now
now what's this all about why is a
militia going to be storming in well
bloomberg says
true inauguration day representative
michael mccall
a texas republican told cnn wednesday
that trump has a responsibility to
defuse the threat
by telling his supporters to stand down
quote this threat is credible mccall
said it's real
the march 4th timing coincides with the
date linked to conspiracy theories
about it being the true inauguration day
presidents were sworn in on that date
until the 20th amendment to the
constitution shifted the ceremony to
january 20th 1920 in 1933.
the warnings also come after capitol
police and federal law enforcement came
under severe criticism
for not acting faster on intelligence
than uh
that the gen 6 protests could turn
violent the latest warnings
caught many in washington by surprise
because they came after a day
they came out a day after acting
sergeant-at-arms timothy blodgett
told lawmakers that capitol police had
no indication groups would travel to
washington
to protest or commit acts of violence
now i'll tell you this they're saying
there's gonna be five
thousand national guards still there
they're keeping the fences in the razor
wire
i said nothing was gonna happen that was
i i was saying it i said i think
nothing's going to happen i think if
people do show up it's going to be a
bunch of people waving little american
flags are going to go home like
conservatives do
and i published a video on january 6 at
1 pm where i was like nothing's
happening it's boring trump is speaking
people are going to go home
the session's happening it's over
everybody and then literally
when that video went live it was like
trump supporters have pushed past the
barricade
than 110 they're attacking the cops and
i was like oh well
i was wrong i was absolutely wrong about
that yeah but you know the circumstances
are completely different
you know a militia well first of all
what militia
second of all where did you hear about
this because if it wasn't on parlor
was it on facebook yeah no no if it was
on facebook why is facebook still up
well because facebook is special yeah of
course they're supposed to know they're
trying to get facebook down
in some way too yeah like the left has
been going nuts against facebook buzz
it was buzzfeed wrote an article where
they were like this is where the
insurrection was planned
and then it was like number number one
is gan number two is parlor or whatever
and then number five it said facebook
yup that's right facebook and
they've been attacking facebook nonstop
over it facebook was where the groups
existed where they were talking about
you know doing this and facebook didn't
do anything about it
well if they have credible information
and they're monitoring and why haven't
they been talking about where this is
chat this chatter's happening how do we
shut this down how do we
prohibit this this is a completely
different environment
there's literally thousands of armed
troops
razor wire unscalable fences an
impenetrable
uh perimeter there no one
is coming with small arms into the
distance
to do right it's to walk into a building
and be like by standing here i'm on it's
glue
that makes me you know you can't you
can't arrest me i'm the president now
that's not how a country works no and
biden along that vein biden doesn't need
to be
in the capital to do a talk to congress
that's a good point
he could be this is the thing we need a
creative
person in in in that position i think
andrew yang would have been a great
great example of that he was super
creative and you need to be working with
the technology we have
to to explain and help people and i mean
it's just so ridiculous so
no no yeah you're right that negates the
devil's advocate point you're making
yeah i hated that i hated it hated doing
it joe biden could
give a speech from space right yeah on
well on facebook
orbit but you know like the launch to
launch his body
he could he could take his phone and
hold it up and be like hey how's it
going america
you know peace just like you know my
americans
you know everything's good see you then
people would like him so much better if
he did is this thing on
is it on nancy is it on you stumble upon
is it on yeah
and then jill biden walks up and smacks
him on the butt like like with elizabeth
warren remember that
dude that was that was messed up do you
remember what happened elizabeth warren
was doing was trying to be like aoc and
it was the cringiest thing ever
and she's doing an instagram live
thinking it's going to connect with
young people
and she's like talking to people and
she's like i'm going to go get me a
beer right i'm going to take a beer now
and then but hold on this is crazy
because she's drinking the beer and her
husband walks up while she's streaming
and he smacked her on the butt
and she like jumps and then she said
something she said i'm glad you're here
i'm happy that you're here and then
trump tweeted probably the funniest
thing he's ever tweeted he goes what do
you mean you're glad he's there he's
supposed to be there it's his house
that was just a great deal i loved it
yeah no but a lot of people are
responding to this bloomberg thing
saying
dude no this is ridiculous it's the
democrats just being like help help the
sky is falling 1-6 it's the end of the
world oh the militias are coming for us
we've always been at war with the white
domestic terrorists in the united states
and you gotta the military industrial
complex will use any
any possible evidence to to enhance the
mil
the militant nature of the society to
gain security powers
we got to be careful about it it's not
it's not just the military industrial
complex it's just
it's this it's the the revolving door
between them and government it's the
government agencies their contractors
and the weapons manufacturers are all
sitting there being like
well i like blowing stuff up yeah don't
you like getting paid to stand there
with a gun
i mean there are my contractors and
they'll guard you for no no reason
because you're afraid i think standing
there with a gun is more like what the
national guard is doing right now enemy
no disrespect to the national guard
like the the blackwater types what is
that company called now they keep
changing the name because of the
controversies
they're the guys who like they go in and
do the real messed up stuff
you know and i wonder man because i i
hear this stuff a lot from
people who support that kind of action
that military action they're like yeah
well you wouldn't be living half as good
as you are right now
if these guys weren't going out there
and doing this stuff black water private
contractors killing people in the middle
east
absolutely oh yeah there are people who
believe like if we're not doing that
you know the petro dollar falls and then
we we collapse and then we're
you know that's it what is america
export man
war culture culture maybe yeah culture
culture is probably one of our biggest
exports debt
that's our biggest expert yeah well
so we had we had uh ethan so plea on the
show and he mentioned
what a lot of people don't realize about
this war is that we're propping up the
petro dollar
yeah we can go into debt with as much
money as we want because
we're pointing guns at everybody
basically so
they got to use our dollars no matter
what it could inflate things for
americans but the economy can't collapse
as long as we got guns pointed at people
so that's i mean that's the whole that's
the big picture i guess blackwater is
called academy now
are you sure it's called academy now i
thought they changed that it's just
academy with an i
not academy no that'd be funny um before
that it was called zxe
they changed it from blackwater to z in
2009 and then to academy in 2001 why do
they keep changing it to avoid bad press
monsanto did the same thing it allowed
itself to be bought by bear you remember
when marlborough changed their name to
altria as well
that sounds like a medicine right
exactly i mean i don't know
i don't know who to believe i don't know
where to put my attention i just want to
know
who is pulling the strings who's the one
that's saying to biden
don't talk who's one saying maybe you
shouldn't do a joint session who's the
one saying no state of the union
one of the coolest things about being
president has got to be doing the state
of the union when you get 500 people
standing up
cheering for you national television 40
million people it's gotta be a highlight
i bet you bill clinton when he first got
elected
i bet he was like man i can't wait to
get this thing done he did his first one
what like 28 days whatever after
inauguration
just enough time to get the speech
written to prepare
to practice a whole bunch to get the
logistics down he was probably let's do
it let's do it let's do it he probably
wanted to do it the next day
february february 17th february 17th
yeah less than a month later
yep less than a month later and joe
biden now in this time
of of healing when are you going to heal
me joe yeah come on joe
come on fat heal me you know you know
what i was thinking
what do you think the the british crown
thought of the founding fathers
dangerous far-right extremists
terrorists
sovereign citizens and
under what authority did the founding
fathers have to actually declare
independence
god yeah literally
literally it's like in the first what a
few seconds well no actually there were
there were a series of elections held
in each state and then some of them were
like ad hoc and like unofficial
and then they sent representatives to
varying degrees they were supported by
they were down at the pub and they're
like
who's gonna go to philadelphia
but then imagine this imagine if right
now check it out check it out it's
awesome
what if there was a very large group
what does that what does it oath keepers
have like 40 000 or something like that
oh i don't know
what happens if just a bunch of armed
groups in various states said
yeah we were elected by our communities
we represent them so we're we're
we're voting for this they better have a
good document to back it up
that's one of the things the founding
fathers had they were really smart and
good
they had a list of was it fourteen
grievances they were upset about was it
fourteen
and redresses yeah yeah whatever that
whatever that means you gotta fix it
yeah the 18th century and they were also
really wealthy a lot of them like landon
it'd be like if elon musk came together
with jeff bezos with mark zuckerberg
with us
you know so so was it our oligarchs at
the time
no they weren't the kings of industry
that's true
they were just well-off dudes for the
most part right it's not quite like
zuckerberg
well but there was an industry per se
yeah there was the east india trading
company
and i guess company would have exists
i'm pretty sure right but sure
certainly but this is pre-industrial
revolution this is pre-robber barons
this is pre
mass wealth of every you know these are
gentlemen farmers
right some lawyers some some army guys
right uh legislators you know yeah
uh and so it wasn't the same kind of
power i don't think but i do remember
studying the american revolution
recently actually
and seeing the fusion between what was
called the cosmopolitan folks
you know like the people that lived in
the city that were all educated the guys
that went and lived in
france and came back they had to make an
alliance with
the religious zionists who lived in
the the countryside right like there
were can people in there still are here
in the united states who believe that
this is new zion that this is
this is a place to build oh yeah oh yeah
this is a place to build
zion and and have new kingdom of god
here in the united
states and they were able to link up
these networks
the cosmopolitan guys worried about the
natural rights and the freedoms and this
and that and the taxation and all that
they they joined forces with the
religious folks who believed that this
was zion and that they were here to
build a new promised land
and they got together because they all
wanted their independence so they had
alignment this was like an early
example of a decentralized movement
that had alignment right because john
adams and thomas jefferson
they weren't zionists right but they saw
they had common
alignment there so they were like all
right let's do it and i've read sermons
actually
from like 1760 and 1770
from preachers in the countryside
telling their people about this
revolution that's coming because god
wants it because
we're here to build a new zion et cetera
et cetera and
it's just interesting to me to as we're
talking about this is to see who were
the characters
like what did they have what they hold
what kind of power did they have and
what was their motivation
what is what would be the analogy today
uh i don't know man i don't think i
don't think it's musk or bezos
yeah but but i think about a lot that
invoking god when i'm talking about
this and the problems and the solutions
like it gets people
rallied and it's kind of scary to use
that because i feel like it's like not
fair
it's it's kind of like playing the trump
card you know and
it's almost like i don't necessarily
believe i don't know if there's a god
necessarily i just don't know
but to say it it works there are people
who will absolutely
pretend to be acting on behalf of god
because they know that people will be
scared or people will be faithful and
they'll give power to these individuals
who exploit them
that's what i see when i see i'll put it
this way
the republicans i think are you know
mitch mcconnell looks at
all these conservatives and goes well
who else you're going to vote for
and the democrats are like well i'll say
literally anything to you to get you to
vote for me because i know as soon as
you do you walk
away now things are a little bit
different though with social media
seeing these memes come from the left
and the right making fun of biden
the greatest meme ever made in my
opinion right now
you see the one where it's big words
it's the red button in the blue button
yeah and it's vaporizing sirians
the blue one says two thousand dollar
checks instead of the guy being sweating
and confused what's the pr which to
press it's dr robotnik laughing
maniacally as he reaches for the red
button
and it says joe biden over it yep it's
perfect because not only does the meme
work
by itself but it's also a meta meme in
that by getting rid of the confused
sweating guy and replacing with an
enthusiastic robotnik reaching for the
red button so assuredly
it's just masterpiece masterpiece meme
but i want to point something about the
funny fathers the one thing they had
the biggest advantage king was three
thousand miles away
yep what was he gonna do about it they
were having these meetings they were
kicking their feet up now the regulars
were going around
and and acting a fool but for the most
part when the when the cat is away the
mice will play
that's a saying right yeah so so the
king wouldn't come into
the colonies and then we brought i
brought this up many times they could
write this letter being like yo
king we out and they send it on a ship
and three months later the king gets it
and he's like oh
harambe i'm gonna stretch a strongly
worded letter back to them
three months later it makes it back and
it's been now six
months since they declared independence
and they're acting as a sovereign nation
at this point so they're like bro that
was six months ago where you been
right right we don't have that right now
they had the whole lantern thing all set
up
one was that one by land two if i see
yep
they were prepared they were super bad
they said they sent that letter off
they're like let's put some lanterns in
please what were the lanterns for were
they
to signify if the british were coming by
land or by sea i'm probably
probably getting all my history wrong my
girlfriend's at home right now watching
this being like your history is not
right
sorry baby they basically had like the
beacon set up so like when you see the
regulars light the beacons and then you
know they put little lanterns in yeah
they also in addition to having the the
distance
um in the time buffer they had the
french which were like this
giant monarch nation that was willing to
go to war for them basically to destroy
england yeah well kind of they were
basically like
war with england so we're not really
helping you so much as you're helping us
yes and men they would have no chance
without the french the french basically
bankrupted their economy yep
and you know yeah and then and then it
caused the french revolution and then
you know that guy who executed all those
other guys
but there were a bunch of nobles in
france who were like i regret that
decision
hey i don't i'm glad they did it but
yeah they destroyed their economy
and then everybody started starving and
the
and then we got louisiana yeah there you
go
right yeah so what like uh 25 years
later
less wow yeah not just louisiana
like the whole central third of the
country yeah yeah and then i think
there was that big swath of mexico and
then you know where the california
territory and then
texas declared independence and then
texas
signed a treaty joining the united
states i i was reading something about
how texas
could have been five different states it
was it was five different
nations within the texas republic
republic really yeah
right so and then uh and and i think
this is recently an anniversary maybe of
their independence from mexico yesterday
yeah
yesterday so i saw i looked at the
document right they were really good
with the documents back then
uh and they're still good well i guess
we're even better with
the documents these days but it made me
think
texans texas folks mexicans
they're put they're people of color
people from texas are people of color
they're actually immigrants to the
united states
when are we going to start treating
texas with the dignity and respect
that we ex we need in demand to give our
immigrant
folks here in the united states and
refer to them as poc and give them all
the opportunities and all the
affirmative action
and all the benefits and honors of a
regime designed around
benefiting pocs and immigrants and
people new to the country
when are the texas republic folks going
to get their dues thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you